[Music]  welcome to my office she told me on 911  operator yeah I lied I'm a full-service  fantasy provider only new is the one to  help me clean up be my bodyguard you  know like the Kevin Costner to my  Whitney Houston Kevin Costner hit shot  at the end you trust me  how much okay so tell me about your  friend the dominatrix we were like in  love once like a friend  sort of weird code about them love it's  complicated  TIFF everyone thinks Dom work is just  about sex work it's really just  liberation from shame what brings you in  today oh you know it's actually it's not  for me it's for me I'm sorry I didn't  it's for me me it's for my husband  you're not cut out for what just  happened in there you're braver than you  think  yep  what'd you do with me that's brave  [Music]  I can never tell me anything because if  I told you what we were gonna do before  we did it then you wouldn't do it hey  [Music]